j'accueille sa trick hernandez
[Musique]
et
suite
[Musique]
je suis tout
je suis pauvre
bon été
m
depuis
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
patrick hernandez dans la commune de
l'isle sur la sorgue près d'avignon
la venue chez patrick hernandez à la
pâte teulet ils sont loin les dancefloor
aujourd'hui patrick hernandez vite au
rythme du chant des cigales et de la
campagne provençale avoir été un des uns
des artisans de ceux de ce courant
musical qu'ils appellent le disco
n'empêche pas d'aimer effectivement la
nature le côté bucolique des choses
s'ils sont tus des planétaire patrick
hernandez lui est resté très france
profond la coi qui s'appelle la place la
place de l'apéro parce qu'effectivement
il ya et a le côté convivial qui est
toujours quitte pas loin il ya un four à
pizza il ya un barbecue sympa pour voilà
pour faire des choses pour les copains
pour vivre en famille pour passer du bon
temps au milieu de ce paradis une place
de choix est évidemment laissé à la
musique
donc voilà l'antre du
l'antre du musicien en fait que que je
suis mort il ya toutes mes copines les
guitares il y en a dans tous ayant tous
les coins et c'est l'endroit où je joue
je viens tranquillement faire de la
musique sur le mur une photo souvenir
d'une photo pour moi en tout cas qui
fait partie de l'histoire
on est en train d'écouter effectivement
bord de ce lac qui est en train de se
faire on est en train de fabriquer à ce
moment là
fort du succès de born to be alive
patrick hernandez continue de composer
des morceaux mais uniquement pour le
plaisir
[Musique]
même si je fais pas de commerce avec
mais avec ma musique
j'ai quand même un besoin viscéral
d'écrire donc ce genre de choses me
servent à ma à me rassurer à me
rasséréné en me disant voilà je peux
encore écrire des chansons je peux
encore faire de belles choses
patrick partage sa vie avec laeticia
c'est elle qui gère aujourd'hui sa
petite entreprise artistes la
gestionnaire et après on se retrouve
effectivement savoir si on est ok tu
mettes bornes ou l'un de ses titres
notamment ben sur une campagne
publicitaire sur un long métrage un
court métrages un documentaire c'est
l'heure d'aller faire les courses et
dans le village tout le monde le connaît
[Musique]
à 7km au boucher favoris ils sont ils
sont deux d'ailleurs vous voyez qu'il 60
comme un ami si tu peux te donner un
petit peu le casque service parce que
justement j'adore les bons produits et
je veux toujours des choses un petit peu
un petit peu point de chute il a bien
mangé et on veut pas le tromper ça si on
vous dit tout sur les pièces à l'étang
des pièces le boucher merci monsieur
passage obligé chez une commerçante
particulièrement fade
chansons danses et oui oui moi je suis
quand même moi ça me fait de l'effet
midi retour à la maison pour préparer le
déjeuner et le compositeur change
d'instrument pour faire la cuisine
proprement nous allons mettre au tablier
une casserole qui appartenait à ma mère
est une 4e qui a mon âge dans son monde
grosso modo donc la main à grasse les
petits oignons le riz que l'on va
rajouter ensuite on va y mettre le vin
blanc et ensuite on y mettra le bouillon
et on va faire parallèlement de très
jolis champignons que l'on va mélanger
avec ce joyeux risotto et on va se
régaler mon épouse cuisine extrêmement
bien aussi mais c'est une telle passion
chez moi que j'ai du temps l'entente du
mal à lui et c'est le piano voix
allez zou peut-il et risotto aux
girolles est prêt chers amis
bon appétit
avant de prendre congé patrick généreux
nous invite à toucher son porte-bonheur
conseille à tout le monde de toucher ce
pauvre de cannes car il porte bonheur
je les touche m a porté bonheur il monte
dans son corps sur ces rythmes disco
la preuve que 30 ans après patrick est
toujours live sur patrick hernandez
patrick bienvenue ce plateau de tout le
monde apparaît merci de me recevoir
alors vous êtes né le 6 avril 1949 au
blanc-mesnil en seine-saint-denis père
d'origine espagnole pharmaciens mère
d'origine austro-italienne alors études
à l'ancien cg pierre curie puis au lycée
de gonesse bonne élève
au départ vous voulez devenir prof
d'anglais tout à fait et c'est pour ça
que vos parents vous envoie en
angleterre dans le kent erreur parce que
là bas vous découvrez les beatles et la
brit pop quoi ai je dit c'est ça que je
veux faire ça je veux faire ça on va
vous commencez à jouer de la guitare à
dieu les études la musique s'empare de
vous alors en 1968 vous devancé l'appel
au service militaire vous devenez
secrétaire du chef d'état-major maritime
de toulon pas très pas très rock'n'roll
quand même ça et je préférais ça quand
même à faire enfin je veux dire affaires
les plus charge de preuve dans la
cuisine donc en fait j'étais un peu un
planqué dans cette histoire mais je me
suis rapidement rendu compte que c'était
pas ma voix coiffe réellement et donc
j'ai résilié mon contrat avant la fin
des avants avant la fin des classes donc
très très très rapidement voilà et la
boue revenez à la musique vous
perfectionner à la guitare dans des
orchestres de bals principalement dans
la région de périgueux tout à fait
quelques années plus tard vous monter à
paris pour une audition chez le disque
flèche la société de l'opo de françois
et là vous rencontrez une claudette qui
vous conseillent de rencontrer un groupe
qui s'appelle paris palace hotel pph qui
cherche un guitariste chanteur
ils sont très inspiré par les beatles
eux franchement sa manche et donc je me
dis je vais probablement signé avec
flèches mais je vais quand même
rencontrer ces gens
et al et après la rencontre très
rapidement je je je me rends compte que
je vois là que je vais partir avec eux à
écrire des chansons et vous signez pas
avec l'autre en soirée je ne signe pas
avec claude alors le groupe pph va
sortir 3 45 tours sans grand succès et
en 1974 il prépare un album sous la
houlette d'un producteur belge nommé jan
van loo associé à un producteur français
qui s'appelle jean claude pellerin et
c'est à cette époque que vous écrivez
born to be alive
donc c'est cette chanson en fait au
départ vous inspirer de born to be wild
de steppenwolf alors bon il est pas mal
effectivement je chante born to be wild
en me disant je ne peux pas garder ce
titre il va falloir que je trouve autre
chose et le premier mot qui me vient à
l'esprit c'est aulas aime le ski est un
pléonasme en anglais mais finalement qui
va faire sa petite carrière par la suite
au départ cette chanson c'est un roc un
vuvuzela chanter trois ans avec paris
palace hôtel sous sa forme rock en 1978
p ph se dissout vous repartez dans le
périgord dans une cabane j'ai tjrs et
baba cool à l'époque oui oui je fais
partie de la génération des vols bakool
effectivement je vis dans les bois
pendant un moment avec une hache à la
tête du lit pour éviter ces incursions
dans dans ma cabane et je je je je vide
d'eau fraîche
ouais même pas d'amour puisque je suis
seul dans ces bois dans cette cabane
alors vous êtes en plein trip bucolique
quand le fameux producteur belge jean
van loo vous appelle il vous demande de
le rejoindre en belgique à ohain au
studio de marcarian au studio cathy pour
enregistrer une chanson intitulée making
of
tout à fait et là pendant une pause vous
fredonnez born to be alive
on vous accompagnant la guitare et 6e
jean van loo qui vous dit mais pourquoi
t'en fais pas un morceau disco pour vous
c'est un crève coeur parce que vous êtes
un vous aimez le rock
pour moi c'était vraiment un gros mot à
l'époque et je j'ai eu besoin d'un petit
peu de temps pour me faire à l'idée
qu'on pouvait effectivement enregistré
cette chanson d'une manière d'une
manière douce
alors lui vous demande de la sphère de
un peu comme la chanson de sylvester qui
s'appelle you make me feel tient un
discours un peu accéléré en plus ils
nous donnent un certain nombre de
références de façon à ce qu'on se bat là
dessus et il me dit surtout tu as une
feuille de route
tu vas aller jusqu'au bout même si ça ne
te plaît pas qui va jusqu'au bout de la
feuille de route fais moi plaisir et
ensuite tu feras ce que tu voudras une
fois qu'on aura le squelette de la
chanson tels que je le veux je joue le
jeu parce que j'ai 30 ans et que je me
dit bon voilà bien vous sentez que
j'avais un truc fort quand même
non non en est l'enjeu j'ai tellement de
cette chanson dans la tête je
l'interprète depuis tellement longtemps
déjà que je me dis qu'est ce qu'il veut
à cette chanson pourquoi pourquoi et
autres fétiches comme ça une fixette là
dessus lui dit c'est une bombe atomique
que nous avons là c'est à dire lui se
rend compte tout de suite hein le
premier soir rennes je rentre avec la
maquette jeu on a fait une maquette à
jemmapes dans le petit studio de
maquettes de d'adamo et je rentre avec
un petit bobino et je fais écouter ça
effectivement à jan van de loock il me
dit tu as fait une bombe atomique alors
vous n'êtes pas au bout de vos peines
d'abord il ya beaucoup de travail en
studio à neuf mois
ensuite pendant deux mois j'en vends
nous se fait rembarrer de toutes les
maisons de disques quand ils arrivent
avec avec le souple finalement il décide
de fabriquer lui même le disque mais ça
ne marche toujours pas et c'est là que
le fils de jean van loo pense après
c'est un maxi single pour l'épauler dj
alors il ya cette opération
effectivement il ya une opération ratée
avec les dj parce que le tempo de band
pirates 133 bpm est vraiment très rapide
par rapport à tout ce qui se fait à
l'époque et donc nous vidons les pistes
à chaque fois qu'on essaye de spirale
dans une discothèque on vit
littéralement la piste catastrophe
atomique c'est une véritable catastrophe
donc toutes les maisons de disques ne
veulent pas du titre
les gens qu'on connaît un petit peu dans
le showbiz ne veulent pas non plus on
entende parler on veut changer mon nom
parce que patrick hernandez mais c'est
quoi cette alliance d'un prénom
irlandais avec un nom de pieds noirs
il faut absolument lui l'appeler
autrement on a même dit que ça faisait
bon espagnol très aimable voilà tout ça
jusqu'au jour où un label italien
distribuer le titre et born to be alive
devient numéro un en italie disque d'or
merci aux italiens parce que nous étions
pour être très honnête à deux doigts
d'abandonner l'histoire ensuite sur
l'allemagne la belgique la suisse
l'autriche enfin c'est mondiale en 79 6
vs france distribue le titre il est
numéro un pendant quatre points en
france ensuite via l'angleterre les usa
vous avez vendu 25 millions de disques
dans le monde 25 millions de disques et
donc sous ce titre est arrivé numéro un
dans 23 pays je crois les deux seuls
numéro 1 qui m'ont échappé son la
hollande où je suis arrivé numéro 3 3 4
et l'angleterre
bien évidemment toujours à côté de ce
qui se fait au niveau de la mode où je
suis arrivé numéro 9 ans quand même dans
le top ten en angleterre ce qui est
extraordinaire pour un français là vous
entamer une tournée de promo mondiale
qui vous emmènera au chili au japon en
australie
vous avez chanté born to be alive plus
de mille fois la télévision j'ai
l'impression qu'on a toujours autant de
plaisir moi à la chanter et le public à
l'écouté en local alors ce qui est drôle
si vous avez ce look 2 me
milord demi meneur de revue avec cannes
et gillet alors qu'en fait ce look avait
été étudié pour une autre chanson était
une espèce de disco de disques au
cabaret music-hall music hall tout à
fait et donc je m'étais dit tiens si je
doit interpréter cette chanson la
télévision je crois que le fait de
mettre un costume de meneur de revue ce
serait se ferait bien vu voix je me suis
donc fournir une canne un gilet un
cantal on a passé un petit chapeau et au
moment de faire ma première télé sur
born
j'étais un peu pressés par le temps je
n'avais pas de look particulier et donc
j'ai pris le ce que j'ai sous la main et
c'est devenu un véritable trade marks
alors il ya une légende tenace mais
fausse qui veut que madonna et était
votre choristes en fait ce qui s'est
passé si vous avez fait un casting de
danseuses à new york pour trouver une
troupe là-bas pour pas être obligé de
l'emmener depuis l'europe dans déjà
effectivement il est so calais chanter
avec moi puisqu'elle n'est pas qu'elle
n'aide pas chanteuse mais elle est
devenue chanteuse veut par la suite il
était simplement dans ce elle est venue
à paris nous habitions 32 boulevard de
courcelles chez jean claude pellerin et
donc elle a passé chez jean ferrat à peu
près une année nous étions très copains
tous les deux j'ai en prévision d'une
sortie éventuelle d'un disque que j'ai
fait quelques séances de photo avec elle
en copains donc on est parti en vacances
ensemble en tunisie comme un copain
copain copain madonna est une [ __ ] enfin
et est une petite brune moi je suis
plutôt branché sur les très grandes
blondes donc rien n'a rien à voir et
donc quand nous avons fait des très
jolies photos qui n'ont jamais servi à
quoi que ce soit puisque au bout d'un an
l'a décidé de retourner aux états unis
chez elle avec un morceau qu'on lui
proposait qui lui plaisait alors à
l'époque elle était très branché sur
tout ce qui était rock punk et donc
d'une manière un petit peu
rigolote mais producteur de l'époque lui
proposait à peu près ce qu'elle a fait
par la suite mais on voulait lui faire
chanter de la pop rock et elle en
voulait elle en voulait pas le volet pas
en entendre parler de lui faire blondy
plus tôt c'était plutôt dans cet esprit
là oui mais il faut dire que c'était une
petite brunette avec des épingles à
nourrice dans les oreilles et jeu très
très court
les t-shirts donc tailladé elle était
vraiment dans cet esprit là et elle
voulait pas entendre parler du tout de
pop à l'époque et en plus elle ne
voulait pas au début il ne voulait même
pas chanter donc elle voulait faire du
théâtre dit si ça voulait faire de la
danse du cinéma du théâtre et en fait
est-ce que c'est pas en voyant les
limousines et les palaces dans
lesquelles vous prêt l'acier mais
qu'elle a eu envie de faire de la
chanson ma foi je pense que si j'ai pu
lui apporter une petite chose je pense
que je lui au moins à porter ça c'est à
dire que de temps en temps moi je suis
un grand fan de macartney donc je jouais
très très régulièrement des chansons de
matières thècle guitare acoustique et
elle chanter avec moi je lui disais tu
vois tu le fais naturellement très bien
c'est le chante quelque chose et je
pense qu'à force de lui dire et à force
effectivement de voir que finalement la
vie d'un chanteur numéro un dans le
monde entier tepa relaxe était pas mal
quoi finalement
peut-être que c'est à lui à ceux d'une
petit clash par la suite elles sont
desservies
ainsi donc les trois minutes neuf
secondes de born to be alive ont fait de
vous une star mondiale
quelles ont été les réactions de votre
entourage à ce moment là bien évidemment
main mes parents ont été très très fier
de moi et je m'amusais d'ailleurs comme
un môme comme un enfant à appeler maman
à n'importe quelle heure de chicago de
rio de janeiro
santiago du chili et elle était très
très fier de ça dans vos parents et ses
frères vos amis ils ont dû être scotché
non il ya il ya des gens qui ont
toujours un petit peu de mal à
comprendre que quand on est dans une ide
dans une aventure comme ça on a plutôt
moins de temps à leur consacrer donc
j'ai perdu quelques amis il faut dire à
l'époque mais mon vraisemblablement ce
n'était pas des vrais amis donc ça ça
n'est pas très grave et ceux qui sont
restés sont toujours mes amis l'été
avant pendant ils le sont encore
maintenant et les mecs du groupe parie
pas rationnel comment ils ont réagi
ils ont très bien réagi ça et ils
savaient ils savaient bien que de toute
façon la version la version que nous
avions fait avec le producteur était
quelque chose que nous n'aurions pas pu
nous réaliser de la même façon
la carrière de madonna n'aurait pas pu
se faire si elle avait elle était restée
en france alors est peut-être fini pour
faire un disque eux mais bon les choses
doivent se faire à l'endroit l'ouest
deauville doit se faire au moment où
elles doivent se faire et je pense que
les gens du groupe paris palace hotel
ont bien ils se sont toujours mes amis
d'ailleurs ont bien réelle je les voyais
toujours bien sûr bien évidemment avec
les médias comment ça s'est passé à
l'époque ayant fait vraiment quelque
chose de retentissantes c'est à dire
pour la france est absolument
exceptionnel d'avoir fait un parcours
pareil j'ai trouvé que j'étais fort fort
boudé par ce qu'on appelle la presse
sérieuse
donc en fait j'ai eu bien évidemment
toutes les presses de jeunes équipes de
l'époque mais la presse de l'échelle et
rock et folk mais jamais rock et pop
jamais elle jamais un jour de frangy
paris match des choses comme ça ou alors
je trouvais que c'était un c'était
dommage parce que pour une fois qu'un
français faisaient réellement quelque
chose notamment aux états unis et que ça
n'était pas pipeauté comme ça l'est
souvent que là il y avait vraiment des
résultats qui étaient tangibles quoi on
aurait pu faire un petit quelque chose
quoi
à l'époque vous gagnez de l'argent je
gagne beaucoup d'argent à l'époque parce
que je vends beaucoup beaucoup de
de 10 que d'une part et que je suis
l'auteur et le compositeur de
l'agencement donc effectivement dès
l'année 79 et surtout l'année 80 l'année
d'après au niveau des droits d'auteur ça
commence effectivement être extrêmement
sérieux mais à l'époque le master vous
appartient pas il appartient aux
producteurs alors le master appartient
aux producteurs qui touche lui son droit
de producteurs et l'édition surtout qui
est un poste très important dans les
droits d'auteur ne m'appartient pas à
l'époque venir faire un master à prénom
a larger en 2000 refait un masters
puisque j'avais un contrat de j'avais un
contrat de 20 ans où je n'avais
absolument pas le droit de te refaire
une version de deux bandes spirale et
donc j'ai refait un master à l'identique
de façon à pouvoir être propriétaire de
mad mark de la chanson et j'ai récupéré
mais en plus mon droit d'édition ce qui
fait que maintenant elle 100% mais je
suis 100% propriétaire de ma chanson au
niveau amoureux ça doit être une folie
non oui ça a été un petit peu une folie
et maintenant j'imagine
d'autant que j'étais célibataire et que
et que j'étais assez joli garçon il faut
lui procure dette et donc ça a été oui
ça a été chaud les sens là quel a été le
meilleur moment de cette époque surtout
la surprise au départ de l'explosion de
cette chanson donc la ggt à la fois sur
les fesses de voir le la rapidité à
laquelle la chose s'est passé c'était
extraordinaire c'est à dire qu'on me
disait demain tu es à vienne en autriche
pour faire une télé je pensais très
honnêtement aller faire de la promo et
quand j'arrivais devant l'hôtel il y
avait
150 personnes massées devant la porte de
l'hôtel
donc je me disais il doit y avoir entre
stewart où il doit y avoir le 4 mai où
il doit y avoir et non les gens
m'attendent et moi parce que j'étais
déjà numéro 1 entre pays est le pire
moment de cette époque
à l'époque de bornes dont 79 80 ça n'est
que du bonheur vraiment que du bonheur
alors ensuite je les composer votre
premier album dans les avions pendant la
promo de born vous enregistrer un disque
dès que votre emploi du temps le permet
back to guy ça marche gentiment mais
beaucoup moins bien que born to be you
là avait effectivement pareil pour votre
deuxième album est ce que là vous vous
dites bon finalement voilà j'en ai fait
une ça me rapporte de quoi vivre
j'arrête à l'époque non à l'époque j'ai
vraiment des velléités de faire d'autres
choses d'autant que je suis un
compositeur assez assez généreux oui et
donc j'ai plein de chansons et
malheureusement je pense que plus le
tube est énorme plus il est gros et plus
le poids et des normes aussi par la
suite
donc il a fallu un certain nombre
d'années pour que je me sorte de cette
situation
mais à l'époque j'ai franchement des
velléités de faire autre chose et un nom
à ma grande satisfaction cbs aux états
unis me dit le disco c'est mort donc tu
sais ce que tu vas faire qui va faire de
la pop et tu vas faire la pop rock
puisque ça tu sais bien faire et moi je
suis heureux comme un poisson dans l'eau
parce que je me dis ça y est enfin
on va reparler de disco quoi et nous
faisons un album et cet album nous
coûtent la peau des fesses
on va londres on va à atlanta en vain à
nashville ont fait venir des musiciens
américains bruxelles on perd on vit dans
un château à part une 3ème plus de fada
et au moment de livrer l'album erreur
une erreur de parcours il faut il faut
dire ça aux jeunes quand on n'a pas le
titre sur un album un vaut mieux le
retenir et je réduis même à la limite en
tant que compositeur dit ok je peux pas
le faire je n'ai pas d'enfants en état
donc je vais demander à quelqu'un
d'autre de le faire comme kim carnes par
exemple des visas c'est son moteur de
son album c'est un des seuls titres
qu'elle n'a pas écrit elle a fait écrire
à quelqu'un d'autre mais enfin bon voila
vous a manqué le titre qui fait que les
hits les américains m'ont dit ben il est
bien ton album patrick mais bon qu'est
ce qu'on va en faire quoi alors depuis
vous vivez des droits de born to be
alive alors 1500 euros par jour c'est
bien honnêtement s'il ya bien quelque
chose que je ne fais plus pour de
l'argent c'est ce métier donc le je fais
tout ce que je tout ce que je fais au
jour d'aujourd'hui je le fais pour le
plaisir de le faire vraiment très
honnêtement les nostalgiques de l'époque
de born to be alive non j'ai aucune
nostalgie parce que j'ai vécu quelque
chose d'absolument exceptionnel que j'ai
fait de l'introspection progresser
longtemps et suffisamment longtemps pour
me dire que c'était une épopée
absolument incroyable improbables comme
on dit aujourd'hui et
je suis absolument ravi de l'avoir fait
c'est quelque chose que je n'aurais
jamais rêvé de faire sur quelle
merveille
quelle quelle merveille d'avoir fait un
standard si c'était à refaire qu'est-ce
que vous ne referiez pas pareil je pense
que je ne referai pas l'erreur du
deuxième album effectivement je vis au
niveau de la vie ce que vous auriez sans
doute préféré c'est vendre un million
d'albums pendant 25 ans plutôt que 25
millions d'albums en un nom on dirait
mon dieu quelle carrière extraordinaire
alors que là on a plutôt tendance de
temps en temps à dire tiens c'est un
coup alors évidemment le coût est un
coup de maître mais bon
voilà ça reste quand même un coût pour
certaines personnes on aime le jeu vous
allez mourir cassoulet qu'on marque sur
votre tombe pas par gone to be alive
non je pense qu'il faudrait écrire si
gilles sommes heureux dans ce cas moi
j'étais très heureux de rallumer la
lumière soit ou pas très digne a sion
les pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
nos latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu